you want to get a jump on life get the
hell out of bed in the morning I call
that snooze alarm the dream killer like
when you put on you when you press that
snooze button you're killing your dreams
so don't touch this button but there are
some actually keys that very very
disciplined people have and here is the
most important one and this would change
your life if you do it wanna be happy
build a life not just the business hate
7 Carmichael and this channel was
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you to you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how you can achieve
anything
ok let's kick it off with rule number
one have a strict sleep schedule with
jockle willing from my perspective when
people ask me all the time though I lack
discipline how can I get discipline in
my life and no one wants to hear this
answer no one wants to hear it do it the
one of the first steps you can take to
impose discipline in your life is to
wake up early in the morning cuz let's
face it when the alarm goes off you're
you got your head on that soft pillow
it's all nice and cozy and warm in there
you do not feel like getting up and so
you hasn't even have a snooze alarm he
doesn't ever hit the snooze in - and you
should not you should not that snooze
alarm is that's insane I call that
snooze alarm the dream killer like when
you put on you when you press that
snooze button you're killing your dreams
so don't touch this button now what I
get now some would say that might be a
little extreme know where people get
worried and people freak out yeah is
sleep is healthy sleep is good for you I
know that I get it and people say you're
telling people not to
no I'm not telling people not to say you
do six hours every night 10 o'clock yeah
I usually go to bed around 10:30 11:00
and I wake up at 4:30 so I get five and
a half to six hours almost every night
you know and and and sometimes I tell
people I
I think sleeping is good I do it almost
every single day no but but people will
freak out and say you're telling people
to be unhealthy I'm not saying that at
all
I'm not you know if you need different
people are they have different genetic
needs for sleep I'm one of those people
that doesn't need much of my four kids
my oldest daughter needs even less sleep
than I do my middle daughter sleeps more
like my wife my son somewhere in the
middle which by the way that means my
middle daughter she gets out of bed when
you get her out of bed she likes to
sleep so I'm not telling people hey
don't sleep but I am saying put yourself
on a schedule and you know you ask why I
don't sleep in if you sleep in if I
sleep on in on a Saturday until six
o'clock ooh that night I'm gonna have
more energy and instead of going to bed
at 10:30 or 11:00 I'm gonna stay up
until midnight because I got a little
bit extra sleep well now that next day
I'm gonna sleep in a little bit more
than all of a sudden Sunday I'm sleeping
in till 7 o'clock now Sunday night I
can't go to bed until 1 o'clock in
morning him you see where I'm going with
this I go into Monday with a lack of
sleep because I couldn't fall asleep so
I just the most important thing is set a
good wake-up time that works for you
where you get enough sleep and then wake
up that time every day if you can also
if you want to have more self love and
confidence check to my 250 for series
they're free the link to join are in the
description below and I looked at it and
I said I'm not a brand I'm a person
successful people do what they hate to
get to where they want to be if you're
gonna speak effectively you have to know
way more than you're talking about rule
number two do the thing you hate first
with Marissa Pierre there are some
actually keys that very very disciplined
people have and here
the most important one and this would
change your life if you do it and I had
to make myself do this it was not
natural at all you must do what you
don't want to do first people who are
hugely successful do this they do the
thing they hate first of all I worked
with somebody who is morbidly obese and
I said you know you have to work out
when I hate working out you know I'm
heavy it's really uncomfortable sitting
there not only have you got to do it you
got to do it first and I had to do that
to see if you don't like going to the
gym you go I'll go later then something
happens the phone rings you eat some
things like I was too late now when you
go first you think later Oh a theme I
went to the gym first I feel like a
winner you got to make a very difficult
call got to ring someone who owes you
money or confront someone that you don't
want to confront and you wait and all
day it's hanging over your head making
you feel so bad but when you do it first
you feel like a winner because people
who have discipline do this they do the
thing they do not want to do first and I
want you to start saying that I was
giving a speech recently and the guy who
came on after me said you know I kept
hearing my voice of everything whereas I
said do what you don't want to do versus
that that has changed my entire business
life and all my staff remember that too
what do we not want to do what's the
worst job let's do that first and get it
out of the way and of course in the
beginning this will be what you do but
you know all happen it starts to become
who you are it becomes easy it becomes
seamless it's a bit like putting lenses
you're I feel seriously odd to suddenly
jerem your finger in your eyes but if
you do everyday comes easy because
that's how habits are formed you make a
habit and then your habits make you so
make your habits amazing and rule number
three the last one before a very special
bonus clip is structure your life
properly with Jordan Peterson the other
thing you should do if you're not very
industrious enough industrious is
discipline yourself and so what do you
do with that eat three times a day at
regular mealtimes that's a good thing to
practice because that starts to put some
stability into your life get up at the
same time I would highly recommend all
those young people out there who are
listening like you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning you know as I've got older I've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because I've
got more and more discipline like get up
early in the morning and get your things
done man
you learn to get up at 6:00 in the
morning and you'll be one deadly
creature especially if you can get to
work you'll have half your damn day done
by the time other people haul their
sorry asses out of bed and so that's a
massive massive advantage look
Will Ferrell Ron Ferrell not the
comedian Warren Farrell the author he
outlined data in why men earn more which
is a book I would recommend by the way
showing that if you work 13% longer
hours you make 40% more money it's
nonlinear so you think why is that well
imagine you have 10 employees and one of
them works an extra 10 percent it's not
much well how often is that person going
to be promoted assuming you have a clue
as a boss it's like you're gonna look at
the 10 people and you think oh that
guy's always here like 45 minutes early
it's like why don't we give him the
promotion obviously right so these tie
these small engines that you can manage
like that work an extra 10% extra 13%
have non-proportional payoffs that's
part of the Pareto distribution so get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses I'm too tired in the morning
I don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals is that's a good
disciplinary routine and then learn to
use a calendar like Google Calendar most
of you many of you out there do not use
a calendar okay a calendar is not a
prison and it's not a tyrant not if you
use it properly a calendar keeps anxiety
at bay it makes sure that you do what
you need to do which is important cuz
otherwise you fall behind but if you use
it properly though it's also helps you
plan what you want to do so I could say
well lay out your damn calendar and
design the days you would like to have
that's what your calendars have is for
so you can put in all sorts of things in
there you want to do and that would be
good for you and that's a really good
really good way to start being more
industrious make a plan you need a plan
for three years you need a plan for the
next year you need to plan for the next
six months you need to plan for the next
three months you need a plan for the
week you need a plan for the day you
need to plan for the hour all of that
all of that I make lists constantly of
what I have to do and they're like daily
weekly monthly yearly right now I can't
look out more than about six months you
know because my life is too complicated
and chaotic but but you need a vision of
who you could be what character you
could have three to five years out you
can't go much farther than that because
life is too unpredictable I think to
make vision that's longer-term than that
subject to there's too much chance
associated with it to spend a lot of
time on maybe you can stretch it to five
years and in rare cases you can have a
ten-year goal but it has to be pretty
low resolution but you want plans at all
those levels of resolution you want to
write the things down and what because
what are you gonna do you're gonna
stumble around and get what you need
you're gonna stumble around and be
useful to other people and it's useful
to be useful to other people you know
they want to work with you then they
want to do things with you they want to
have you around they trust you they open
up opportunities for you and if you
stumble around like you're blind you're
not gonna get anywhere and then you're
gonna suffer and then you're gonna be
bitter and then you're gonna be cruel so
that's a bit that's hell that's a bad
out
now I have a special bonus clip with
Thomas Frank on how to change your
identity that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
what is your new sleep schedule going to
look like number two what's the thing
that you hate that you're going to do
first and number three what does a
properly scheduled life look like for
you and if you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you give me a
hashtag to leave down the comments when
you're trying to change your behavior
forget about the goal you're trying to
achieve the external outcome and instead
focus on the change in identity you want
to happen this is a concept that I first
read about in James Claire's book atomic
habits which I highly recommend by the
way and there's this passage near the
beginning of the book that really
encapsulates it well so I'm just gonna
read it to you here imagine two people
resisting a cigarette when offered a
smoke the first person says no thanks
I'm trying to quit it sounds like a
reasonable response but this person
still believes they are a smoker who is
trying to be something else they are
hoping that their behavior will change
while carrying around the same beliefs
the second person declines by saying no
thanks I'm not a smoker it's a small
difference but the statement signals a
shift in identity smoking was a part of
their former life not their current one
they no longer identify as someone who
smokes so the general idea here is that
once you've embraced a change in your
identity you're gonna find yourself
acting in alignment with that change and
if you're wondering why exactly this
happens the third chapter of Roberts
Hilding these book influence the
psychology of persuasion has a great
explanation for it
essentially humans feel this natural
compulsion to act consistently with
their past decisions as he writes in the
book once we have made a choice or
taking a stand we will encounter
personal and interpersonal pressures to
behave consistently with that commitment
those pressures will cause us to respond
in ways that justify our earlier
decision and shifting my mindset in this
way has been incredibly helpful in the
past couple of months
if you want to know how to fail your way
to success check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I like micro failure
I like micro failure I hate macro
failure like death of your business is
bad but